bonjour claude beaujour heureuse de vous
retrouver dans cette matinale de rtl
france alors la visite de l'eeie a en
préambule des rencontres du 29 novembre
prochain à vienne que peut-on en
attendre de ces frais en sachant qu'on
l'ait vraiment à un moment clé de cette
négociation monsieur raphaël grossi
c'est en effet aujourd'hui à téhéran
pour voir finalement quelles sont les
dispositions d'esprit de ce gouvernement
puisque la négociation de réinsertion
des américains dans l'accord du 14
juillet était qu avait été fait il ya
plus de cinq ans et sept cette
réinsertion et qu'on est conditionnée
par l'acceptation par l'iran de la
reprise de tous les engagements qui sont
dans cet accord et effectivement
monsieur grossi avait déjà fait une
mission à téhéran et à environ six
semaines qui avait assez bien réussi il
s'agissait en l'occurrence de
l'entretien des caméras de l'aiea du
changement d enregistrement et du fait
que les iraniens dfa serait pas ces
enregistrements autrement dit leila
reprenait l'entretien et la logistique
de toutes ces caméras de surveillance et
dans le fond il a abouti ça a fonctionné
je crois qu'il s'entend assez bien avec
les iraniens il les comprend assez bien
mais évidemment demain il va faire
rapport au conseil de la ja et il doit
dire voilà voilà ce que j'ai compris
naturellement devant l'ensemble des
membres de l'aea
et on voit bien que on est à un moment
clé parce que les principaux
protagonistes se positionne comme vous
savez les américains ne sont pas
directement à la table de négociations
ils sont derrière les rideaux comme on
dit dans un hôtel en face de l'autre
côté de la rue et participent à la
négociation par européen interposés ils
sont bien entendu en contact avec tous
les gens qui participent à cette
négociation y compris les russes et les
chinois mais tout est mais l'intérêt des
iraniens de revenir à la table des
négociations alors que rien sans
influencer leur décision concernant
l'enrichissement nucléaire
leur objectif c'est la levée des
sanctions économiques la lgv et maximum
au maximum des sanctions économiques
parce que l'économie iranienne n'en peut
plus l'iran ne peut plus exporter
librement son pétrole et la population
naturellement le ressens comme une
situation extrêmement pays donc il ya un
risque politique pour le gouvernement
iranien s'il n'obtient pas l'allègement
des sanctions économiques
sinon leur suppression complète c'était
aussi et l'objectif de l'administration
précédente en iran est d'ailleurs
beaucoup de progrès avaient été faits
mais malheureusement il était pas arrivé
jusqu'au bout on constate qu'à une assez
grande continuité la négociation était
suspendu pendant cinq mois puisque le
nouveau gouvernement iraniens voulaient
faire l'inventaire dans le fond du sujet
et regarder les choses sous tous leurs
aspects donc effectivement aujourd'hui
le gouvernement iranien continue de dire
comme le président qui ne cherchent pas
à acquérir la bombe que ça ne
l'intéresse pas mais évidemment qu'ils
le croient par conséquent on regarde ce
qu'il a fait et à partir du moment où
donald trump a décidé la sortie de
l'accord évidemment ils ont commencé à
ne plus respecter un certain nombre de
clauses enrichir de l'uranium
au-delà des 3 des fameux 3 67% qui sont
dans l'accord allant jusqu'à 60% avec
des quantités qui approche du seuil de
fabrication de la bombe alors là
l'administration byden sera t-elle
enclines à faire des concessions et qui
peut influencer finalement cette
administration américaine dans un sens
ou dans un autre claude tu pas sûr que
l'administration américaine s'apprête à
faire beaucoup de concessions elle veut
que l'iran applique tout ce qu'il ya
dans l'accord là dessus d'ailleurs les
iraniens disent tout ce qui est dans
l'accord mais pas plus or les américains
voudraient un peu plus parce que cet
accord il a été conclu pour une durée
est limitée et qu'est ce qui se passe
après 2030 il ne porte que sur l'aspect
enrichissement d'uranium ils portent pas
du tout sur les éléments balistique
pas du tout sur l'activité politique de
l'iran en direction des pays de la
méditerranée que ce soit en irak que ce
soit en syrie que ce soit au liban et
effectivement les américains voudraient
au moins que l'iran s'engage à parler de
ces sujets là alors il est possible pour
trouver un compromis moi je pense quand
même que l'administration de bye-bye
donne voudrait arriver à un compromis
mais ça sera très difficile parce que le
gouvernement israélien bien que divisés
ne veut pas d'accord
/ ce que le ministre des affaires
étrangères et même le ministre de la
défense considère qu'un compromis est
possible elle étaient peut-être
acceptable le premier ministre non ce
compromis pourrait être d'ailleurs à un
accord transitoire pour quelques années
de façon à se donner du temps de façon à
réintégrer les américains et les
iraniens dans le fonctionnement de
l'accord initial quitte à discuter pour
la suite merci beaucoup que de blanche
maison pour votre éclairage en éclairage
à retrouver bien évidemment sur les
réseaux sociaux l'édito diplo de la
matinale c'est tous les mardis matin sur
rtl france merci